thank you whoo thank you is truly an
extraordinary privilege to be here
tonight I'd like to start off by
thanking the Academy of course to the
governor's to the organizers and
supporters that were able to give us
recognition for this film and then also
for all the other wonderful films that
have had the opportunity to be shown
this week secondly I'd also like to
thank all of the collaborators who I had
the pleasure of working with for the
past year for the sound designers the
composer my wonderful voice actors who
all helped to take this object this
inanimate object him to give it life I
really wouldn't been able to do without
them and then of course finally to be
brief I'd like to give a quick thanks
also to my family to mom to dad to lean
to Anya who were able to encourage me
from the very beginning to help me find
my creative voice as an artist and
filmmaker in particular I have to shout
out also to my dad who I can remember
when I was 10 years old he he took me to
a rock filled out in Ohio we were fossil
hunting together and we found this this
fossil the one that was in the video it
was a trilobite an ancient sort of
insect like organism for millions of
years ago embedded in this its fossil
and I was so excited and is actually the
source of inspiration for the character
that was in the film it's amazing how
those moments as a child sort of reflect
and carry with you and sort of provide
inspiration for the work that we make as
artisan the future lastly and this is
sort of a sort of an unofficial off of
the script thing but I wish also as sort
of an unofficial way at the academies to
also partially dedicate this film to Tom
and Jane Dustin whom were my neighbors
back where I grew up they were
naturalist's and
extreme defenders of the environment and
I believe that the heart of this film
was really driven by what they had
taught me as a kid thank you very much